herzlich willkommen zum neuen video ich
habe in letzter zeit einfach die
schnauze voll von meinem kopf gehabt und
ich dachte mir mal
es ist zeit für eine kleine veränderung
deswegen muss heute mal eine kleine
erneuerungskurs ganz genau ich bin auf
mein name ist und man hätte ich ihnen
scheißegal schreiben
ich habe tatsächlich entschluss gefasst
ich habe jetzt knapp zwei jahre lang
oder zumindest mal anderthalb jahre lang
wir diesen kopf wachsen lassen die haare
darauf wachsen lassen dass sich etliche
zopf tragen kann mittlerweile kann ich
ihn tragen
ich muss sagen es war schön wir haben
gedacht wir haben geweint wir haben
unseren spaß gab dem zopf aber jetzt ist
auch gut jetzt muss er ab ich hab kein
bock malz hopfen ich bau ne neue frisur
weil es halt auch kein bullshit video
aller mein gott haare abgeschnitten
prank plätze es gar nicht passiert
sondern ich schreibe mir einfach
wirklich gehabt
mit dieser schere max wärme strom aus
die ich abschneiden seien dort geschaut
dass hier sind die haare von so lange
sind die aktuellen und ich würde auch
sagen beginnen mit den ganzen spaß
schneid ab noch ein bisschen höher
bisschen höher was du bist wirst du den
schnitt selbst setzen
ich setze schnitzel floss das oft würde
sagen hier ist eine gute länge müsste
schauen da gehen locker zehn zentimeter
als ob ich will ich will ich will gar
nichts
ich seh ich dich okay heute okay leute
okay leute gesagt ich kann die schere in
den an den haaren spüren aber wie gesagt
will aber nicht lang
weiter bestehe dafür gleich das halt
leute hier links haben wir die normale
strähne die welt abgeschnitten haben
also die neue haarlänge noch ziemlich
lang und dass hier was etwa zehn
zentimeter aber deshalb wirklich 10 cm
ich habe lange mit dem gedanken spielt
das zu machen aber dann hat mein großes
idol ein großes gemacht
und wie könnte ich so lange sein
sie sind die ganze zeit sondern da war
okay leute das was wir jetzt machen ich
traue mir ich sei nicht wirklich zu mir
selbst die haare komplett abzuschneiden
deswegen gehen wir jetzt zum friseur
meines vertrauens dann wird endgültig
alles abgeschnitten
ich bin sehr leid ich habe sebastian
schon länger gesagt er solle sich die
haare abschneiden
meine oma gesagt weil meine oma hat
gesagt mein gewissen schande
mein puls
also bisschen länger als max hat ich
habe die so vollgestellt das partie
gefordert und 10 von schweizer zeit kurz
hinter kurz vor den schaltern vorne so
huber
kommen so die hilfen reichen raus dass
hier noch eine ganze ganze menge hatte
ich immer noch im kopf hat eben noch mal
in der stadt wissen was eingekauft unter
anderem das hier ja noch eine andere
stadt auf uns schauen + co ich gehe ja
normalerweise nicht mehr viel geld für
klamotten aus aber heute dachte ich mir
gönne ich immer den haarschnitt plus so
leicht erinnert wird dass seiten zeiten
schlechte zeiten wie gesagt haben die
kommentare was mein base und schaut oder
meine alten langen haare